now the Kevin Frazier on location at CBS
3 in Philadelphia with his new doctor
Phil interview
hi Kevin yeah Nancy tomorrow dr. Phil
will air a rare and very emotional
interview with Sinead O'Connor the
singer now as many of you know she has
attempted suicide on multiple occasions
and it was actually Sinead who went to
dr. Phil to get help
just not dying and that's not living I
see this this iconic talent alone in the
middle of the night in a motel room in
New Jersey I mean it's like hitting
bottom the 12 and a half minute video
made headlines last month the last in a
string of Facebook posted starkly
illustrated the singer struggles with
mental illness for dr. Phil it was a
plea for help
he couldn't ignore she says she
attempted suicide eight times in one
year we were able to in 24 hours get her
out of a motel room alone in the middle
of the night crying to a hundred-acre
treatment facility in the rolling hills
of Tennessee
now Sinead shares the shocking details
of her breakdown in an intimate
interview with dr. Phil when I took an
overdose about three weeks ago I wrote
my suicide note
which she have died without your help I
think this could have gone real bad real
soon now dr. Phil also told me that Jen
AIDS been in treatment for a little over
a month and for the most part
everything's positive but there are
those days where it gets rough and she
will get combative as a matter of fact
she'll actually leave treatment but he
said she always comes back
you